malgré ce bon soir merci d'être avec
nous alors ce rapport du sénat est un
rapport très détaillé très choquant qui
a fait beaucoup de bruit quand il est
sorti en décembre dernier alors d'abord
quelles sont ses méthodes
d'interrogatoire très prononcée très
poussée on parle bien de torture ah oui
la simulation de noyade
c'est d'abord cessé après si c'est
vraiment là la pire net de torture et ça
a été appliquée à des des gens innocents
ainsi que des gens probablement pas
innocent mais on ne sait pas très bien
parce que tout ça a été fait dans des
conditions hors hors de la loi alors des
normes juridiques
on a beaucoup parlé la simulation de
noyade n'y avait dans ce rapport on
détaille beaucoup d'autres méthodes tout
aussi humiliante et terrible oui pour
moi est apparemment pour george bush
aussi la pire chose c'était de mettre
les gens nus à nu et 2 et 2 et de les
faire porter des couches pendant des
jours pour qu'ils se salissent pour tout
simplement pour les humilier et bien sûr
il y avait des coups de poing il y avait
on est projeté contre le mur de contre
les murs on les enchaîner on les
laissait a croupi pendant des heures
c'est la torture physique
il ya aussi la torture mentale et
simplement de les mettre à faire pour
porter des couches c'est vraiment c'est
dégoûtant
c'est désespérant mais c'est dégoûtant
c'est désespérant parce que ce sont des
amériques a remis par les américains qui
ont commis ces actes horribles contre
contre les gens contre les gens de façon
un peu aléatoire parce que le grand la
grande leçon de ce rapport c'est que
après tout ces tortures après tout cette
ce programme de des interrogatoires
renforcés entre guillemets ça n'a abouti
à rien c'était à 100% inefficace entre
herman à ce que l'on sait
davy week ont déjoué des complots qu'on
sauvé des vies américaines et que
c'était absolument essentiel pour
protéger la patrie après le 11 septembre
alors voilà qu'on apprend et encore
ce n'est pas un rapport inventé par des
gauchistes ou par des gens qui détestent
ébauche l'auteur principale de ce
rapport c'est un ancien du fph des
agneaux jones qui connaît très bien le
milieu d'interrogatoire et la grande
ironie
après après tout cette seule lecture
c'est d'apprendre que les méthodes plus
douces les méthodes conventionnelles a
pratiqué par le fbi a été beaucoup plus
efficace que la torture dallas la
violence physique pratiquée par la cia
alors comment se fait-il qu'il a pu
durer si longtemps parce que ça a
commencé au lendemain des attentats donc
en 2001 et ça a duré jusqu'à ce que
barack obama arrive quoi 2009 on a mis
fin cela il a mis fin il a mis fin
officiellement en 2009 c'est bush qui a
vraiment mis fin au programme six parce
qu'il était tellement gêné par les
méthodes de torture décrit dans un
briefing
mais il a continué continuer à mentir au
grand peuple américain au grand public
et de mai vous demandez comment c'est à
st ça pue dur et tellement longtemps
c'est à cause des mensonges très
efficace raconté par les hauts
responsables les onze hauts responsables
de la cia on aurait pu penser que la cia
aurait été ébranlée après des
révélations comme celle là or vous dites
dans votre préface que la cia est plus
puissante que jamais qu'elle aurait un
budget secret d'autour de 50 milliards
de dollars sa propre armée privée
qu'elle mène ses propres guerres qu'elle
commandite des assassinats c'est
surprenant même assez surprenant sauf si
on connaît un peu la politique
américaine
de nos jours et la politique étrangère
de barack obama dépend beaucoup sur la
coopération de la cia c'est eux qui
lancent des attaques de drones
c'est eux qui s'occupent des assassinats
donc ayem
et au pakistan donc ils sont utiles pour
barack obama alors il a été très prudent
vous vous rappelez peut-être de ces
constats après la sortie du la
publication du rapport il a dit oui
c'est pas très bien qu'on a qu'on a
pratiqué la torture
mais quand même ses chansons des
patriotes les agents contraire personne
n'a été traduit en justice persiste et
bien pas une seule poursuite en justice
contre un seul responsable de ce
programme dégoûtant donc quand on dit ça
a été inefficace a été contre-productif
et non seulement contre eux pour du
productivisme aintenant que tout le
monde musulman tout le monde arabe
connaît cette histoire
vous pouvez me imaginer que les gens qui
font la propagande ici ici c'est pour
d'état islamique y pour tous les tout ce
que vous voulez quand mu musulmans
radicaux utilisent le rapport
les frasques de la cia pour soulever
suscité la colère de la rue
justement le contexte en fait à changer
à cette montée du groupe armé état
islamique et on peut se demander s'il ya
des leçons à tirer de l'expérience
américaine pour les démocraties
occidentales
aujourd'hui par exemple canada a proposé
de prolonger sa mission militaire en
irak de l'élargir à la syrie et on veut
aussi donner plus de pouvoir aux agences
de sécurité ici justement à cause de
cette menace alors quelle leçon il faut
tirer de ça mais je commencerai avec un
retrait des troupes
je suis très contre l'intervention au
proche orient et la politique style bush
estime obama avec les attaques de drones
etc ou les civils meurent à côté des
radicaux
mais pour le canada c'est très important
de lire ce livre
les canadiens ont vraiment je dirais à
une obligation de citoyens de lire ce
livre ou au moins le sommaire du livre
dans le livre parce que justement on
prône au canada à des interrogatoires
plus douce plus - renforcée que que
celle des américains
oui mais quand même pendant sept jours
si je comprends bien il y aura sept
jours de détention où son mandat son
mandat dans la prochaine loi c'est toute
chose peut peut passer pendant sept
jours avec un ou des individus
soupçonnés de
de crime ou de deux têtes d'intention
contre le canada les positions demande
plus de surveillance qui dit qu'il faut
pouvoir surveiller un peu les agences de
sécurité donc il ya des garde-fous
est-ce que ça ça aurait pu empêcher les
dérives aux états unis si la cia et
avait fait avait été plus survie mais on
avait la surveillance soit disant du
sénat et vous avez vous vous voyez que
sa nana ça n'a pas marché s'était
complètement inutile parce que la cia
avait le pouvoir
la capacité de 2,2 de mentir pendant
cinq six ans sans conséquence
alors si vous imaginez dans trois ans
une commission de votre parlement où un
chef de sécurité un chef du dint
services de renseignement canadiens
répondent à des questions qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pendant l'interrogatoire de
télé tel suspect vous pensez qu'il va
répondre honnêtement comment sait-on on
peut on peut dire n'importe quoi si la
personne n'y a pas de témoin et c'est ça
ce qui s'est passé en secret dans les
dents et si noir du ces de la cia ya eu
des des interrogatoires non sur v où on
pouvait faire n'importe quoi à n'importe
qui et on l'a fait mais c'est ma carte
un merci beaucoup merci beaucoup c'est
merci à vous